ladies and gentlemen if you aren't aware
Silicon Valley Bank almost went belly up
and we actually have the two guys who
drove it into the ground ladies and
gentlemen welcome Zach and Walid guys
come on in here
[Applause]
why were you guys tweeting about Bank
runs and starting a bank run why did you
guys yeah why'd you guys do that I saw
your deleted tweet of last night was a
bankrupt
a bank run is like an evil spirit it's
like it only you conjure it by just
speaking its name yeah so why'd you do
that you know I didn't want to encourage
a further Bank oh yeah you and your
friends are just casually talking about
a bank run I mean I did take out a
ton of money but that's because I'm
going to Vegas oh okay yeah I was just
there oh yeah why were you there oh
siva's wedding oh nice who's
Siva oh yes nice Alina's sea of these
nuts fit in your mouth
[Music]